bring in Charles Barkley the Hall of
Famer and proud he's not an Auburn grad
but he went to Auburn for a couple of
years Charles good morning how are you
[Laughter]
[Music]
did they give you an honorary degree in
Auburn no no we don't do those you know
you have to be smart to go to Auburn I'm
doing pretty good for a college dropout
you think what did you do for
Thanksgiving I had a bunch of people at
my house bugging the hell out of me it
was a great restaurant in Arizona called
baby case they do two deep-fried turkeys
and I had a bunch of people over that's
in Scottsdale
yeah nice and how excited were you in
Auburn beat Alabama
it was awesome brother it's always fun
to go to the Iron Bowl I was there and
it was a beautiful day perfect weather
so I was glad to [ __ ] with my my boys
did Alabama recruit you they did but the
they had signed a guy named Bobby Lee
hurt who was the best player in the
country and he had a gun 'edit Phillips
who was a stud and I didn't think I
could get to play there so but I made a
great decision Harper's the best thing
you ever happened to me it's for the
decision if you didn't go to Auburn
where were you going everything's gonna
be UAB University of Birmingham they had
gene Bartow so it was easy going to be
that I was really close with my mother
and grandmother I was gonna stay closer
they could see me play all the home
games so it was it was gonna I made a
great decision going to Auburn there was
going to be Alabama
it was sa it's gonna be one of the three
to be honest with Alabama Auburn a UAB
but I made the best decision did they
try to get you to play football in high
school I played football in high school
one day
really hidden out there
[Laughter]
I did I played football one day you know
I'm not made to play football reasonable
football and boxing on my two favorite
sports it takes a true warrior to go out
there I mean it does I mean I respect
football players I do and I respect
boxers because man when you go out there
it's a real deal they not out there
joking around
what kind of football player would Shaq
have made come on man you know you can't
play football he's a big dude he is a
big dude that's just more to hit brother
he was vision would he play think about
that I mean he could probably a big
offensive lineman but that's pretty much
it but he can't play on offense that's
just too much space to him I would think
like a defensive tackle because he
doesn't have to get after the passer he
can just stand up and put his arms up
you disrespect the football
I don't know Shaq's pretty athletic he
was he was in the day but he's so big it
would have been tough for him to do it
brother I don't know I wanted to ask you
about this you got teams scoring a
hundred and thirty hundred and forty a
hundred and fifty points it's fun well
what changed in the NBA well we got a
lot of bad teams I think we all been
disappointed in the level of basketball
so far this year we want to see the
starter we had high hopes for a bunch of
teams and they're just not shown up and
the bad teams are really bad and you
factor in no defense teams up and you
can have one those nice where you make
some threes against a bad team you're
gonna have a lot of blowouts but a
hundred and fifty points well that's
inexcusable Dan that's just bad team bad
defense I mean that's guy I mean you got
no pride I mean you resist that you got
when you give up that
many points you really don't have any
pride defensively I make it that's when
you've given up I think this I think
they had 80 points at halftime yeah well
when you're doing that you just you're
not even trying defensively but it feels
like there's a new philosophy instead of
milking the shot clock to get a shot off
in seven seconds they're like
everybody's sort of adopting what the
Rockettes have done with Mike D'Antoni
well I think it's actually they trying
to adopt what the Warriors did when they
won a championship X amount of years ago
everybody just shooting threes as quick
as possible now there's no mid-range
game and you just shooting threes and
you see they got that cut then I said
summarize it the Warriors who have they
had the three greatest shooters who
probably ever lived there were seven
teams in the NBA shooting more trees
than the rocket excuse me than the
Warriors that's absurd how can the team
with the three greatest shooters who
ever live how can you have bad
basketball players shoot more threes to
knows guys I mean think about it Danny
the right the Rockets are an anomaly
because that's the way they do but there
was six other teams in the NBA shoot
more threes than the Warriors
that's absurd I mean I mean it just
flat-out absurd playing it simple you
all in Lucca don't check yeah I like him
I'd like to see them get porzingis
involved more i watch them play a couple
times like lucas baller but i really
like to see him get porzingis more
involved and also I'd like to see him
well especially when he when Lucas not
in the game because I watched him played
last week against the Clippers and he
just got stomped when Luca couldn't do
this thing I was like feel free to pass
the ball to pros English to get him
going to either stud but when they
played the Clippers Larry I watched the
entire game took notes and everything
and Luca had an awful game because the
you know those guys got the two best
perimeter defenders in the world on one
team but they never passed the ball to
porzingis except when he's standing at
the three-point line
I mean I've run someplace to get him to
ball down low
to get us some easy baskets so but they
don't do that they just get up on a loop
and say go do it and that's not gonna
work against the good teams James Harden
you know you like he got 60 points in 31
minutes
I should he be pacing himself because I
always this is my big knock on you know
the Rockets and James Harden once we get
to April May then it feels like they run
out of gas
no they just plan against the better
teams a good W and that's the thing
about the playoffs day and that's when
you play against the good team so they
have strategy they have coaching who not
gonna let you do everything you want to
do I don't think they run everybody runs
out of gas
I mean you plan every two or three days
so you're not tired but you know the
other teams like nope you're gonna do
something different we're not gonna let
you
the refs don't call as many free throws
I bet if you look at James Harden free
throws he's probably shooting five to
seven less free throws a game and a
playoff he does during the regular
season but the ref lets you played just
a little bit more but the main thing did
you just plan against the best teams but
man you put up 60 in 31 minutes and work
I you know I said first of all I'm not
comparing James Harden to Michael Jordan
and Kobe Bryant
but James Hart is the best offensive
player I've ever seen with today's rules
with the three he's a terrific tree
shooter when he gets it going he can
drive he's physically physically strong
but when I said that last year people
looked at me like I was crazy I said
this guy's the greatest offensive force
we've ever had in the NBA from a little
guy I mean Karim's to greatest him and
will greatest scores and four big guys
but it's for his guards this dude is the
best offensive player ever because
Michael and Kobe one great three-point
shooter change is a really good
three-point shooter and he can drive on
anybody because he's because he's he's
got a great body
I mean he's strong he's athletic I mean
he has it all yeah invites contact and
you know Jeff Van Gundy was on the
a couple of weeks ago and he said that
you can't have your hands in front of
you guarding Harden because harden will
always initiate contact Van Gundy said
have your hands out to the side and let
him take the three-point shot you have
to chew you have to choose you can't try
to shut him down on both you know going
inside or shooting threes he doesn't
miss free throws I don't want him in the
lane at all and I if he's gonna take the
three and he puts up 25 threes then okay
I'm gonna have to try to survive with
that what do you think of that logic I
don't like that logic to a certain
degree I like what the demon ugh is he's
played against two teams in the last two
weeks who doubled him every single time
he ran a pick-and-roll I would play him
like that
cuz those other guys ain't good enough I
mean passing the ball to Clint capela
at the top of the key it's not gonna
hurt you but they played against the
Denver Nuggets about a week and a half
ago they doubled him every single time
and I forget the second team they did it
they both of them teams beat them pretty
good I would double him every single
time said okay capela you know anybody
else can make a play I don't think they
can make enough plays to win four out of
seven but I would double James Harden
every single play go back to the today's
rules with harden I it feels like Kobe
might benefit more from today's rules
than Michael would it feels like Kobe
had a little more extended game and this
isn't fair to Mike who if he was coming
up now would develop you know a better
outside shot or a three it felt like
Kobe in today's rules would probably be
more effective than Mike because Michael
was 225 free-throws a game I mean that's
the difference you can't with no hand
chicken those both of those guys would
shoot a lot a lot more free throw these
be shooting the same number of free
throws a James shoot don't it different
is I think James a better product
consistent three-point shooter Michael
Michael was a good jump shooter but I
don't think he was a great three-point
shooter and Kobe I don't
he was a great three-point shooter but
just to the record those two guys are
better than James I don't want to
disrespect those guys but the way the
rules are today well you can't touch
anybody and the way James gets can get
on the streaks shooting threes he's the
greatest offensive player I've ever seen
in my opinion yeah I'm there with you I
said it last year I said you know it
might be a style that you're not
interested in watching I'm fascinated by
it but I am disappointed in defenses
sometimes because if if I ever see James
Harden isolated I wanted I want to throw
something at the TV because he should
never have an isolation
you should always send somebody at him
and I see these poor young players and
they're out there and they have no
chance against him and I you know so
some of it is coaching a lot of it is
you know the league feels young
inexperienced and Harden is brilliant
he really he knows how to rig the system
for him and he's done an unbelievable
job well the thing about it is you let
him play one-on-one he's gonna get a
shot every time a good shot I mean I've
always said a great offensive player
either gonna score get fouled or get a
good shot he's gonna be three for three
he might not make the shot but a Michael
Jordan a Kobe or Kevin Durant guys like
that who are great scorers they're gonna
get a shot and I didn't they might not
make this shot but when you got guys who
are that gifted offenses like I say
these are gonna get a good shot they're
gonna score they gonna get fouled so and
that's always an advantage for a great
scorer but I would never let James play
one-on-one because he liked to say he
got to get your team in foul trouble
because he in all say this he's probably
the best player I was saying who makes
contact then obviously we agreed in it
Allyson bump you 100% of the time he was
coming at your full speed you just
didn't notice it because he was so
slight but James is so physically double
he hits you every time the same way and
you counted you noticed it because he's
so physical but Allen Iverson I used to
watch him and study him on tape of time
he bumped you every single time that's
one of the reason he was great even
though he was little all he do is get
you off him a little bit he bumped you
every single time and that's what great
offensive players do that's why people
always say what are the stars always get
the calls I said well first of all
that's that is some truth to that
but all great offensive players always
made contact with the defense and they
get pissed when I read the whole call
that's why they always look like they're
complaining I tell people all the time
like any time I made a move I wanted to
hit the guy just I didn't want to knock
him down I want to knock him off balance
a little bit so I could get my shot off
so when the rest when the ref calls it
probably sixty-two percent of the time
but the other forty percent when he
didn't call it out you see guys jumping
up and down but if they would actually
sit down and look at the tape the other
one making contact with the defense Dan
I know they Harden's great and
initiating contact George Gervin was on
the show a couple of years ago and I
said who was the guy that you saw that
that game and you knew you couldn't wait
to get to the arena because that guy was
guarding you and he said Kevin greevey
and he said it in a way he goes Kevin
grieve like he he knew he was putting up
40 on Kevin greevey who was the guy that
you knew you were gonna have a you
couldn't wait to face you know I hated
Kevin McHale because he's the best
player I ever played against he's one
guy who was so much bigger than me with
his long arms and his great moves I had
a difficult time guarding him and then
on the other and he was so long you know
you know he was so long it was tough for
me to get my shot off if I had to face
him up
but who was easy who was the guy you
went you know I'm putting up a big
number tonight you know damn I'll be
honest with you I felt like that against
everybody but I'd say the one guy I
hated the one guy who kicked my butt all
the time was Popeye John I used to hate
that dude and I have no idea why I have
no idea why cuz he wasn't very athletic
but for some reason he knew all the
little
trick and he drove me crazy when I
played against him like he like he
kicked my butt more probably than any
player that I played against well you
probably wanted Byrd to guard you didn't
you Oh Larry I didn't want any of this
[Laughter]
you probably didn't want any piece of
that off you know with his offense
though oh you know he was great great
great but like I say you know in my day
I mean it was a challenge to play
against him I mean nobody's gonna stop a
great player yeah but listen I'd rather
play against him than Kevin McHale
because Kevin was just so much bigger
than me with those long-gone and Kevin's
to this day under than Tim Duncan had
the best low post moves of any power
forward to ever play the game it was a
lot easier for me to guard Larry Bird
could intercept pick some things for him
I mean cuz he would never stop moving
but he was hilarious great as he was now
he wasn't one of those guys say hey
here's the ball score so and those are
the guys that's a nightmare like James
Harden you're like hey here's the ball
score and everybody know he's gonna get
it and he still can score get a good
shot but Leonard wasn't like that he'd
be moving all around you turn your head
for a second he's over there in that
corner I he ran off to picks off McHale
and parish picked he's in the other
corner you turned your head for a split
second he remind me of Reggie Miller who
never stopped moving
Ray Allen Klay Thompson's like that guys
who never stop moving those are the
tough guys cuz you know they always say
you're supposed to keep one eye on your
man in the ball I'm like well first of
all that's not possible all the time you
got to turn your head full of spit
second when you look around your man is
in the other corner it's not a
comfortable feeling Chuck cook great to
talk to you Congrats on all Byrnes win
against Alabama and we'll catch up with
you soon have a great Christmas Thank
You Chuck that's Charles Barkley for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV stream
for free on Br
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]